this makes my heart happy seeing you all
together hi michelle how are you doing
hi i'm good listen i've got to jump
right into the mess though because the
fellas i just talked to them and i
started
feeling that you all were being kind of
loud
on purpose to mess up their interview to
take away their shine
girls up staging the guys why would they
schedule these interviews on the same
stage
that's a great question that's so
interesting because we kind of thought
the exact same thing
about them seems like something they
would do not
they were loud i especially heard
leblanc's
squawk and then um
and then we they're very quiet right now
which makes me nervous yeah i know
i got nervous like there's something
wrong what's gonna happen
leblanc just heard squawk maybe maybe
you should be a little nervous
i don't know but you should be hopeful
i'm scared
it was an incredible time we became
best friends yeah i'm gonna cry now how
amazing was it actually to be back i
know you guys are friends anyway to be
back in this set on the set with you all
all together kind of
in this zone again i had slept so well
the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all just
feeling good the first question like
how do you feel i was like and then
started crying and then i walked on the
set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends that
even though i see
these two a lot i i still was just like
jenny are you crying as much as me she's
like yeah it was just the most emotional
thing and then today she can't stop
crying so
okay so it wasn't just courtney you all
had that moment uh
yesterday it was just a real oh yeah and
once her
gates opened then it was i couldn't shut
it off you couldn't even i could plug it
i didn't no
nothing when i watched the episodes i'm
laughing out loud because
you all make me laugh so hard lisa so i
wonder then
um do you think about in that moment
like where would phoebe be
2021 or do can you even wrap your brain
around like where she
and everybody else would be today yeah
i mean i've thought about it i don't
think it makes for great storytelling
but because i think they're all
i think they're all just really happy
and then they get together
once in a while i don't think they live
super close together but
you know well david said joey would have
10 kids and he would be running a garage
somewhere
okay that's an interesting direction no
longer yes
gave up acting i think that i would be
uh like you think i i
was thinking maybe like a competitive
mom at a school like
a mom that was always trying to you know
organize the bake sale or something her
kids are
probably too old and she just still
wants to make sure the big sale goes
well
i know you guys know that tv casts don't
always aren't always as close as you all
are
so what was it about this experience
with these people that bonded you like
it did
and so you're also close all these years
later all i can say
is that there was something that was
laid
down at the very very beginning that
kind of went into our neural pathways
that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
and it was without question there was
never competition there was never
if there was ever a conflict it was
instantly addressed and handled
no no eggshells it was just
something and i it's unexplainable but
we're the most grateful women that i
know who have
been able to be a part of something like
this oh my
[Music]
here we god where's the tissue box
[Music]
the cost of friends you know the
anticipation we've been bugging y'all
about this for a year
and now here it comes so what can you
tell us about this final version
well i think sorry no no no no no
it doesn't um it doesn't i i think
everyone is
even more excited to have this
experience having been locked in a home
for
so long and going through the last year
was
this past year was extremely hard
heartbreaking hard just to to endure
and i think it's going to be an even
more welcomed
um time for people to to see it
there's a lot of things that were
planned before covet happened
and i was so surprised in filming this
how great it still was with all of the
stipulations and
just how how you know ben winston was
able to pull this off
and bring and he's our producer but yeah
and ben winston should get an award for
everything yeah
just fyi amazing i love it well thank
you guys so much and i have to tell you
courtney
david um was here last week co-hosting
with us and we decided if there's going
to be a new theme song to this reunion
coco should re-record it and she should
sing
the opening to friends because her voice
is so dope she has a beautiful voice
thank you
love that idea